right good morning folks everybody good
after the conference party last night
good year is currently 2017 let's
imagine the air is now twenty thirty
seven and teleportation has finally been
invented hooray
and I teleport us all to here where are
you there France ya lo Rue du something
sounds French Jersey yeah so this is why
I live if you wanted to really find out
where you were you could walk down this
road down this leafy Lane and hopefully
bump into somebody and are somewhere am
I
or we could use technologies to solve
this problem we get out our mobile
devices our smart phones we open up on
the maps apps we hit the little dot that
satisfy me and it gives you something
like that does this help does this help
you understand where you are a bit we've
got a nicer overhead view now it's still
quite zoomed in isn't it still not
entirely sure where we are how do we
solve this we do the pinch to zoom out
thing there we go there coz that's where
I live this is a small island just off
the coast of France it's quite complex
isn't it it's quite cluttered that
picture you can see lots of the textures
the different shades of green it's not a
particularly great way to navigate to an
unfamiliar environment again how do we
solve this problem with technology we
just removed the satellite imagery there
we go
now Jersey becomes a bit clearer we can
see the intricate network of roads and
lanes and please to start sison the
place names if you don't know where
Jersey is so again this is kind of
useless so we have to do the pinch to
zoom out a bit more context as another
islands next door called Guernsey this
here on the on the right is France we
zoom out one more time I there we go now
we can start to get some some better
context about where Jersey is zoom out
one more time whose vintage Jersey here
a couple of people right so this summer
coming when it will when the weather
warms up because
no we are so British climate essentially
you should come to Joseon holiday when
you come through the airports also to
one of the harbours grab one of these
things it's a visitor map the Vista map
is a really good simple guide to getting
around Jersey tells you where to go what
the place names are that sort of thing
it's broke up into four quarters nice
simple map it's mostly accurate it's a
kind of schematic thing there's a bit of
information and detail missing but this
does tell you the major route ways sites
points are interest there's a town area
we can zoom in a bit
again this is mostly accurate you'll see
that there's a a marina here which is
blue it kind of implies it's covered by
water
it is for 12 hours of the day if you
drive your boat in there and park it you
will come back at some point and find
it's laying on its side so that
completely dries out and also there's a
bathing pool at the bottom just where it
says sand Helier that gets flushed twice
a day with the earth that the tiler
movement we have which is probably
useful because I mentioned the kids
peeing it and some of it whatever so
contrast this map which is very simple
to this one
this is an ordnance survey map of Jersey
and it's much more detailed it's but
it's been created by you know modeling
and surveying and it's got every single
streets and every single curve and every
single building and every single
building shape and the various terrains
and the contour lines and it's it's very
very detailed this is a little bit
trickier to understand but it's got lots
of information if you know how to
interpret it the thing both these maps
have in common is they show points of
interest so when you come to Jersey what
should I go and see well one of the
things you should go and see is this
it's called a list with Castle it's a
small islets off the south coast of the
island because of the history around
Jersey the French and the British Connor
invading there was lots of
fortifications and this castle was built
in the fifteen or 1600s and it's a
really beautiful example of like a kind
of medieval style castle lots of big
granite stone work that sort of thing
when you walk to the center of this
castle there is a kind of natural high
point and you get closer and you get
closer and you get closer and then you
see something a bit odd you've got this
beautiful granite building and someone
stuck this really ugly concrete thing on
top you like what why would you do that
you walk around the castle a bit more
our history is important here so during
World War two this is my short history
lesson during World War two
Jersey was occupied by the German forces
the Germans imported a bunch of concrete
and built stuff like that they also
built gun emplacement so they
refortified the existing fortifications
and again it's only by reading the signs
around the castle that you really
understand this history and it allows
you to kind of marry these two different
styles of architecture together in your
mind how do you find out more
information about the history where do
you buy a travel guide book before you
come to Jersey which you should the
summer of course physical book
electronic book tells you lots of really
interesting information about Jersey
maps points of interests walking routes
sites itineraries and so on and so forth
so what does this got to do with
anything
I'm not being paid here by the Jersey
tourism bullet by the way to promote
Jersey although they should do I'll come
back to that stuff later
so visualize this talk is really about
visualizing documenting and exploring
software architecture one of the things
I do at the moment is travel around the
world and I help organizations
understand software architecture
I run a one or two day workshop and a
big part of that workshop is a it's a
software architecture kata so here are
some requirements go away creative
solution draw some pictures to visualize
it the diagrams that are flying pass now
are real examples from real workshops
there's some really really crazy stuff
going on from these diagrams I have 20
gigabytes of photos like this but we
could just spend the next three or four
days as looking all these diagrams
sometimes when I'm listening in to what
the groups are doing so this is a group
exercise three or four people sometimes
somebody in the group will be drawing a
thing like a shape or a line or a symbol
and they will actually say things like
this right this thing doesn't make sense
that we're drawing but we'll explain
later
whoops and there's always this
assumption that diagrams will be
presented and there's always this
assumption that you know there's a
narrative needed to accompany the
diagrams to really unlock the meaning of
the diagrams and of course this is fine
if you're working in a nice or group
environment and you're having like an
hour and a half or two hours to design a
software solution you're doing some
pictures you're having those
conversations in front of whiteboard
those conversations those diagrams those
icons make sense to you one of the
really nasty tricks I play is I get
groups to swap pictures and guess what
happens you get this gigantic what
moment going on because they've now got
a bunch of diagrams they don't know what
they mean
they've got funny symbols funny icons
it's just really really hard to
interpret so I ask people well what's
tricky about these diagrams you have you
know give me some review here and they
say well we're not sure what these
shapes of arrows mean you know why these
lines pink or reds or what somebody had
a pink marker pen they used it you know
what is this diagram actually showing
what level of detail is it showing why
have we got multiple diagrams which
order do you read the diagrams in and so
on and so on and so on the actual design
parts that exercise is really simple
it's a really really simple little kind
of batch application with a web app
typically but the complexity in this
exercise is just communicating and
visualizing and sharing these ideas you
know the intent behind the design so our
seems what did you find challenging and
they all say the same thing we don't
know where to start with the drawings we
don't know what types of diagrams we
should be creating here what notation
should we really be using what level of
detail do we design down to and what
level of detail do we draw pictures down
to these are two very different things
of course
I run this workshop now a lot
twenty-five plus countries ten thousand
plus people have done it I have no
empirical evidence to back anything up
right this is all purely anecdotal based
on this sort of sample size but
essentially software architects and
software developers really struggle with
this stuff time and time and time again
everybody struggles with this exercise
it seems now we might be thinking well
there is this thing called the unified
modeling language who uses UML here one
I did ask that question out loud didn't
I one okay so all that words well then
there and that's again what I'm seeing
more and more so um oh used to be quite
widely used maybe ten twelve fifteen
years ago now hardly anybody's using it
I'm seeing many many more organizations
and teams where nobody on on the team
understands UML and typically and
actually I think this is optimistic it's
sort of one out of ten people I mean
given this audience this is way way up
to Mystics course so this raises a
rather interesting question is UML worth
using for describing software
specifically architecture and design
ideas and the answer is it can be the
problem with UML is it doesn't
necessarily have the right type of
abstractions that are useful to describe
software systems so let's imagine we
want to draw a picture of a user using a
software system you can't do that in UML
UML does not have a software system box
what you end up doing typically is using
something like a component or a package
shape and adding a little stereotype of
brackets to say this is not a component
as you might think it's a component it's
actually a software system if you're
having to jump through these sorts of
hoops you have to question whether UML's
the right notation to use in the first
place and this is why lots of people
draw boxes and lines types diagrams if
you've never drawn after it's a diagram
before where do you go for inspiration
well Google's a good start
except it's not if you go and do a
Google search for soft
architecture diagram you get that page
after page after page of very pretty
colorful block pictures the type of
things you can do in PowerPoint Visio
OmniGraffle keynote lucid chart except
to accept etc and when I go and see
organizations and they let me look at
the documentation I see stuff like this
typically on the you know SharePoint or
confluence pages and lots of these
diagrams don't make sense lots of these
diagrams suffer from exactly the same
problems as the hand-drawn diagrams are
kind of wizard quickly before why it's
not this important goods communication
rule seeking to be you know leaner and
more agile and move fast to respond to
business changes and business needs if
you want to do that as a team you need
good communication that's all this is
very simply about there are two things
we want to talk about then really number
one is notation and number two is
content notation is super simple to
solve here are some tips I'm going to go
through these in any detail but you know
these are the types of things you want
to think about if you're drawing ad hoc
boxes and lines diagrams to describe
your software systems be conscious of
the notation you're using every time you
invent an icon or a symbol or a specific
line type ask yourself why and make sure
that's written down with a key or a
legend one of the things we joke about
and software is that naming stuff is
really hard do you think this is true
yeah it's to two degree isn't it if
naming stuff is hard it doesn't make any
sense whatsoever that most of our
architected diagrams are just boxes with
one word in one name if the name of the
thing is wrong there's just a degree of
ambiguity creeps in these diagrams so my
simple my really simple advice here is
just add more texts to your pictures
it's as simple as that there's an
example diagram the one on the left is
what I see people normally do lots of
boxes single word add more text describe
what those boxes are what technologies
are these boxes one of the
responsibilities of these boxes and
again I'll show you some more examples
this later so it notations easy
contents much more interesting back in
the late 90s Philip Christine who's one
of the Rough Guides Maskelyne for a
process he created this thing here
called the the four plus one view model
of software architecture and it's a way
to think about describe and communicate
software architecture from a number of
different angles essentially and he says
this to describe a software architecture
we use a model composed of multiple
views or perspectives anybody using this
today anybody use it in the past a
couple of people so essentially what
this is all about is you take a use case
a scenario a feature a user story and
you document it from four different
angles you have a logical view that
talks about your functional building
blocks we can call them modules or
components if we want to you have a
development view which Maps how your
functional logical building blocks map
on to code there's a process view that
talks about concurrency and there's a
physical view talks about infrastructure
and deployment there are lots of other
ways to do this as well there are lots
of other architecture books and those
architecture books processes present
their own enhancements or extensions or
versions of this and the thing you'll
notice about most of them is that they
have this weird split between the
logical view and the development view so
here's a picture of my software system
it's made up of logical things and
here's a very different picture of what
those logical things look like if
they're hopefully mapped code somehow
and this is weird I don't know why we've
chosen to do this in the past you can
see this in some of the older design
methodologies like SS ADM there's a
logical design step and then there's a
physical design step and this doesn't
make any sense as far as I'm concerned
because the two intertwined of course
and I think this leads to this
statements a lot and I see this in
organizations around the world they have
these beautiful looking handcrafted
architecture diagrams printed on like a
zero paper with a plotter last updated
1998 something and then they say yeah
these items are really nice but they
don't quite match the code by the way
right so they're lying to you what value
to these diagrams have you is there just
a big crack that you're covering up or
do you actively use these diagrams on a
daily basis so again it's a mismatch
between what we think about on the
diagrams and what the code looks like
it's fantastic book if you're really
interested in software architecture
there's a fantastic book by George
Fairbanks it's called just enough
software architecture in this book
George Fairbanks talks about the model
codes GAAP and it's exactly this thing
so we have a model of our software a
bunch of diagrams if you will and that
model of our software doesn't quite
reflect the code or vice versa and
explaining this is very very simple so
when we're having an architecture
discussion we might use abstract
concepts to describe the things in our
system we might have a discussion using
the terms component and module and layer
and service and subsystem who's a
c-sharp net developer here right so
that's a good chunk you in c-sharp is
there a component keyword Oh in c-sharp
is there a layer keyword oh but we often
think about our software as being made
up of layers and components and we have
these conventions where we say things
like well a namespace equals a component
or a namespace equals a layer or maybe
an assembly equals a component and
sometimes it's that mapping of you know
real-world code concepts into the
abstract concepts that doesn't make
sense and is often missing so that's the
sort of prom winners whole fear before
we can even attempt to solve this
problem this gap we have a much much
more pressing issue and that is even now
in 2017 we don't have a common language
to describe architecture we don't have a
common language to describe the things
our systems are built from now this is a
pretty bold thing to say I must admit
because we've been using words like
modular component and services layer for
years and years and years so surely we
must understand this
who likes a quick quiz do a quick quiz
excellent right what's that it's a map
of London perfect we're in the right
place what's this blue thing in the
middle
it's the terms it's a river what is a
river wet yes to flowing body of water
one way or the other perfect so we
learnt this stuff when we were kids we
know what a river is and we know how to
go and find other rivers so I something
else what's that it's a yeah it's a
top-down floorplan for bathroom what's
this thing here it's a toilet
excellent what is a toilet seriously
there's an exercise here for later right
so it's another body of flowing water
ideally one way again we learn this as a
kid we know how to identify depending on
country other toilets and we can go and
identify more toilets if want to perfect
any electrical people here excellent so
what's the sort of squiggly thing down
here there's a zigzaggy thing a resistor
what is a resistor resist something or
other yeah slows down the flow currents
are not less compression if I had a box
of electrical components here on this
table with resistors and capacitors and
switches and LEDs and all sorts of stuff
could you come to the front rummage
through the box and find me resistor
yeah and if you knew the colour coding
you could work out how strong that
resistor so again we know the resistor
is we can identify it we can pick it up
touch your feet up see this crease is
far too simple right let's go
exponential what's that
see it was sat for that what
okay let's let's let's backtrack what
type of diagrams are these class
diagrams closed for not quite component
right so these are UML component
diagrams in in various different formats
given that these are UML component
diagrams what are each of the boxes on
the diagrams components thank you yeah
so each of these boxes is a component
that's what this UMail shape or notation
means
what's the component uh-huh something
that does something I ran my workshop
late last year and somebody says it's an
imaginary thing right so you've built
six software systems out of imaginary
things it's a lot it's a logical unit
function yeah that kind of works as a as
an explanation let's look a bit closer
these diagrams so that one there is
stereotyped database so that is a
database component because there's a
little stick for the lollipop saying
JDBC that sounds like there is a Java
interface into that database so that
sounds like a database right like my
sequel instance or something
so that's component on the left-hand
side we've got some components that are
labeled UI or application I don't know
whether these are web applications
console applications mobile applications
I don't know if these are separately
deployed or things
the slice through the middle you
remember what I said about naming and
adding more text I have no idea what
these components are what they do
seminar schedule brilliant I don't know
whether these components are micro
services right they're standalone deploy
of all things with a remote interface or
they could be part of the application
there's just so much ambiguity on this
diagram the other one is absolutely
brilliant so this is a real example from
modeling tool I went to live which one
there's a firewall component
I guess there's an XSL stylesheets
component what what else have we got
there's a web server component and ASP
pages component I don't think it ever
drawed an architect's diagram like that
my favorites of course is the business
logic component that's epic to boil this
down to its absolute essence right
imagine we're building a software system
the software system is is built from a
web application that talks to a database
if you go and lock up the word component
in the dictionary it means part of
something bigger for some people in the
room the web application is a part of
the system it's a component of the
system for other people in the room that
login component is a component both
makes sense but they're just very
different levels of abstraction it's the
irony of the ubiquitous language we talk
about domain driven design and creating
this ubiquitous language between us as
techies and the business people we don't
have our own ubiquitous language that's
exactly what this is about if you look
at the environment language UML it tried
to do two things it tried to create a
ubiquitous language and a ubiquitous
notation to describe the language I
think having the common set of
abstractions I think creating the
vocabulary is actually much much more
important than the standardized boxes
and lines if you look at something like
electrical engineering if I draw a
little squiggly thing we know it's a
resistor I really would like us as an
industry to get to that point but I
don't think we're there yet and I think
we need to focus on the abstractions
first and let the notations evolve
naturally this might sound a bit foolish
go get to tourist maps of London and lay
them out side by side the two toys maps
of lund will show the same things won't
they the various areas and districts and
the Thames and the tube lines and the
bus routes and the shopping centers and
out sorting so the two maps of London
will show the same things the same
abstractions but they might use a
different notation different shadings
colors line styles icon
cymbals how do we decipher the maps
whether the key in the corner perfect
let's do that it's so a map is a really
nice simple example of a common set of
abstractions with the self-describing
notation and that's a really really
powerful concept so how do I think about
software systems for me a software
system is made up of a number of
containers a container is something like
an application or a data store it's a
web app a mobile app a console app a
Windows service a database a file system
and Amazon s3 bucket something when you
in resolver ever it's something that
needs to be running for your system to
work for me my containers are made up of
components so I want to use word
components means something running in a
runtime environment essentially yeah
it's a grouping of related stuff with a
nice clean simple interface and because
I mostly deal with Java and c-sharp my
components are built from classes
ultimately and we're done so this is a
really really simple hierarchical
structure to describe the static
structure of a software system software
systems containers components classes if
you're using f-sharp not really classes
are there so maybe an f-sharp it's not
components and classes maybe it's
modules and functions casts cow same
thing JavaScript modules and functions
modules and objects so you might have to
take this hierarchical approach and kind
of map it to the tech that you're using
this is my language this is my set of
abstractions we can then draw some
pictures to visualize this stuff and
this is what I call the c4 model our
system context diagram shows my system
and stuff around it we zoom into the
system boundary to show containers we
zoom into each container to show
components and then we probably stop
what I normally find is going down to
the level of components is normally
sufficient to describe my software if
you want more detail and specific
components yet you can zoom in if you
want to if anyone's started to work
around big data you might have heard of
Schneiderman spectra if you have a huge
amount of stuff to work with you want an
overview of something first you don't
want to zoom in and filters just
specific parts of that set and then you
want some details on demand and it's the
same sort of thing
this is a really quick SIL example when
I moved back to Jersey 2008 I built this
thing here Tek time CA it's a really
super simple content aggregator for the
local tech industry I've now since taken
it down list local people businesses
blog posts tweets out something this is
a system context diagram for the tech
drive system that box in the middle
that's my system and these are the
things around it different people users
actors roles personas and different
system dependencies if this is
interactive like a Google map we select
the tech toys box we pinch to zoom in we
get to see the content inside it so this
dashed line here represents the system
boundary and all of the boxes inside the
system boundary are the containers that
make up the tech drive system there's a
web app a standalone app and some data
tools you'll notice my diagrams I have
lines descriptions technologies the
arrows are annotated so on and so forth
again if we're interested in some more
detail we select one of the containers
we pinch the zoom in we get to see
components so this is the component
diagram for one of those containers and
the story repeats until we get down to a
class diagram so nice simple set of
hierarchical diagrams that actually
reflect the structure and thing we're
building and it's all about maps it's
the same thing as I presented at the
start we have different levels of maps
for different audiences depending on the
different types of stories that we want
to tell and we do want a way to zoom in
from one level to the next and there to
be some real traceability here of course
this is just about static structure I am
trying to you know tackle this static
structure first so we have the codes up
to the system with a couple levels in
between once you understand that static
structure the other views that you might
want to use to describe your software
are super simple if you have a feature
or user story or use case that you want
to show how it works at runtime you draw
a UML sequence or collaboration diagram
showing how elements in the static model
interactive run phone whether they are
classes components or containers up to
you if you have a map of your
infrastructure Reuters firewall service
that sort of thing whether it's
virtualizer physical there's a mapping
between containers and infrastructure
that's your deployment mapping again
super simple to do so so I teach on my
course people tend to love it suddenly
this week asked me if I was going to
submit it to a standards body which sort
of scared me I'm not sure how I answer
the question and I force people to do
this on paper and it really bugs them
because there's me saying add more text
to your diagrams and now they're going
nuts or angle this little tiny text I'm
pissed on pieces of paper so after this
at some point I always get this question
well what tooling do we recommend and
whenever I polled a team I said well
what tooling to use currently and they
say how we use video OmniGraffle or
Gliffy or draw the i/o because we use in
the cloud now or lucidchart or Die Agri
diagram Lee
there are lots and lots of these kind of
general-purpose diagramming tools out
there and I'm sure you've used them in
the past as well
and because the diagrams I'm showing you
just boxes and lines you can draw them
in general-purpose tooling you create a
box you put some text in it you make the
text the right size the right color you
line it up we draw another box with the
same thing you draw a line between the
two boxes you open up the properties for
the line you try and figure out which is
the start and end of the line to put the
right Arrowhead on the right side you
always get it wrong first time around
trust me and you kind of rinse repeat
and it's a very manual laborious process
the other thing of course with something
like Visio or a static diagramming tool
is that if you have the same box on two
diagrams if you change it on one diagram
it doesn't magically change on the
second one so if I rename a person a
user component I have to go and rename
that thing on other diagrams with great
power comes great responsibilities
come on its 2017 the building people do
this you know you've been tasked with
architecting the Burj Khalifa do you get
video out I hope not but the building
industry uses you know sophisticated
complex modeling tools okay a nice
three-dimensional model of the thing
we're building and we surface different
diagrams different
use from it cross-sections and side
elevations and so on the irony of this
of course the irony of this is that we
build these tools for other people to do
modeling but we can't do modeling
ourselves have fun is that once you have
codes why don't we just reverse engineer
diagrams from code has anybody tried
this what happens you get an awful mess
is that because your code is an awful
mess sometimes but more often than not
these diagramming tools are just showing
you everything at a very very low level
of DS of course apologies for that the
Java nature of this example but
everything I'm going to tell you is
exactly applicable teashop so in the in
the Java world there's a framework
called spring spring does everything
that's we need to know part of spring is
an MVC framework for building a model
view controller web apps like air speed
on MVC this diagram on the left is is an
architect's diagram for a sample
application called the spring pet clinic
so this is a Twix a ssin a toy code base
to illustrate how to build spring MVC
applications basically it's a three
layer architecture controllers services
repositories you download the code of
github it looks like this you load it
into your IDE you say IDE generate me a
class diagram of all of this lovely kony
get that this is a small sample toy
application we like 20 or 30 things this
is not your enterprise systems with
millions and loads of code I did I
promise you I did try to move these
boxes around so there were no
overlapping lines is basically
impossible it's too much detail if we
take a more thoughtful balanced view
maybe we exclude some stuff that's not
really important so having an
architected discussion and again this
varies code base to code base but in
this example if I start to remove some
of the really boring things like your
mighty utility classes and my data
structures that don't have any business
logic in I can generate a much much
simpler diagram by removing stuff in
there from that diagram and once you
start to rearrange the boxes I can now
redraw that layer diagram again so the
boxes at the top the classes are
softened my web app controllers there's
a bunch of service stuff in them
all that's my business logic layer my
service layer and all of the things down
here are my repositories my decorator
subjects but this is still fundamentally
showing code isn't it it's still showing
me classes interfaces links between
these things if this was a Google map
this might be like Street View so let's
imagine I live in Jersey I never been to
London I fly to London for the first
time I'm an estate on a train to London
somehow I walk out of London Victoria
Station and I'm lost
uh-huh but I have my smartphone with me
so I open up my smartphone and I do the
find me now thing and then I switch to
Street View so I'm standing outside the
train station I have the street view in
real life and Google Street View here
well that's a dumb idea isn't it it's
like the same thing I'm just wasting my
roaming data what I really want to do is
zoom out of Street View to get a more
you know high level overhead view and
that's the thing how do i zoom out from
this picture well I have to make some
assumptions if if this is showing me
codes and classes and I want to see
components I have to work out what a
component means for me in this code base
and this is my approach for this code
base so I'm going to treat all of the
webapp controllers a set of components
because they're separate things and I'm
going to bundle up the interface and the
implementation class for everything else
down the bottom there's also some little
tangle of helper classes so we may or
may not want to include those in our
component in our component definition so
of course the diagramming tools when you
reverse engineer the diagrams and code
they see codes they don't see components
and this is not a new problem of course
this is just the model code a thing
again we go back in time there's a great
paper if you want to read it the first
two opening paragraphs basically
illustrate the whole thing you ask a
developer to draw your diagrams and
system their work you're going to get a
nice high level picture you reverse
engineer something from the code you get
a totally different picture the
low-level picture auto-generated is
super accurate super precise but it
doesn't necessarily match the way that
me as a
you know how I think of the co-pays and
one the big promise here is that the the
architectural information doesn't live
in the code it gets lost at some point
George Fairbanks to the rescue right so
in George Fairbanks this book he talks
about adopting an architecture 11
encoding star this sounds very grand is
nothing more than dropping hints and
metadata into your code base so that
your code base does reflect your
architectural ideas and intent in very
real terms this is stuff like adopting a
naming convention consciously so if I
have a diagram here and there is a box
that says logging component let's make
sure something in the code is names
logging components so there's nice
one-to-one mapping maybe it's a name
spacing or packaging convention maybe we
say that every box on this component
diagram maps to an assembly or a
namespace maybe it's about adding
machine readable metadata like
attributes or annotations to say this is
architectural e important this is our
component for example I also want to get
people away from the using video not
because video is horrible but what it is
but it's not the right tool to draw
assets pictures now there's something
called an architecture description
language has Emily use one of these
things before I thought that might be
the case these things are essentially
textual descriptions of architecture
normally static structure so you write
some text and that text describes your
software system to some degree there are
a bunch of these things out there darwin
koala there's one called acme believe it
or not and they never really left
research in academia
if you do a search for darwin
architected description language online
you end up on a university website
there's a PDF file you can download with
the language grammar it's horrible you
did not want to go to conference all the
teachers do these languages no no no
however as developers we like texts that
we we can diff text we have lots of
tooling to support and read
factor text we can check text in text is
good for a number of reasons so why
don't we take all of these ideas and
throw them into a big pot and see what
comes out so what I've done is I've
created an execution an executable
architected description language and
there are two open source projects on
github structure icing for Java and
structure Iser for dotnet and
essentially what these things are is
they are small class libraries that
implement the c-4 model we're going to
show you some Java code the c-sharp
version is almost exactly the same
except you have to uppercase the first
letter of the method names that's it
what we're doing is we're really
creating model of our system so let's
create a model too that describes the
spring pet clinic system the spring pet
clinic system is nothing more than me as
an employee of the clinic using the
system that's it there's no more
complexity here so basically I can
create that description using code so
I'm going to create myself a software
system object and give it some
properties to represent the the spring
Peck clinic system and I'm going to
create myself a person objects to
represent the user and I'm going to say
that using the API that the employee
uses the system done that's it so it's a
really nice simple kind to the main
specific language to describe
architecture you're just building up an
in-memory object graph from a container
perspective this is nothing more than
our web app talking to our database
again we can model out the code create
container object for the web app create
container object for the database why
the two things together in various ways
when it gets down to the level of
components I don't want to have to do
that why because it's long-winded and
it's error-prone yeah we try we add a
new feature you might change the list of
components in your system so built into
both libraries there's a component
finder guess what the component finder
does it finds components the naming is
not hard after all you plug in different
strategies because every codebase is
different every codebase has a different
approach to how it thinks about
components so that part you can plug in
your own strategies naming conventions
so go and find me all of the things that
end in the words components or service
or controller for example in this case
there's a pre-built spring component
finder strategy it knows how spring
applications work all it essentially
does
it looks for special Java annotations
and then using some bundling logic it
basically joins together the interface
and the implementation class and it also
finds some supporting helper classes so
you run the components can you run this
against the compiled version of the code
so you run it against your assembly in
the.net version it uses static analysis
and reflection to go find stuff once you
have a set of components and the
relationships between them it finds
those as well you can write some more
code say things like go and find me all
of the data access objects or data
access components you just found and
make them use a database so again you
got complete control over all this stuff
so that creates you a static model of
your software with n crates and views
there are a bunch of view classes in the
library the view classes map onto the c4
diagrams we create a context view a
container view component view and you
get control over what you can add or
remove from those from the pictures and
then we need some pictures alright so
this is just a little styling program we
need some pictures we need to visualize
this and of course what we have here is
a model and once we have a model we can
visualize it in a million different ways
anybody like graph this here nope so in
the Java library there's a graph is
exporter so you take one of the views
you export it to the graph biz format
you throw it into graphics and you get
an automatically generated diagram in
the UML fans here one I know there's a
so if you've heard of plants UML plant
UML is at a textual way to create UML
diagrams again there's an exporter for
plant UML and it generates you a bunch
of picture so these are UML diagrams to
describe the spring pet clinic system
context diagram container diagram
components so all of these components
were found by the components can plus
all the links between them I want pretty
diagrams for presentations and you know
pretty diagrams that are just nicer so I
bought some Tony constructor Iser
structure Iser is a software service
thing I have to do it carefully I'm not
trying to sell
raisa there is a commercial aspect of
this if you want to do lots of kind of
company sharing stuff but there's also a
free version that you can create
diagrams with with the free version what
you do is you upload your model as a
JSON documents to the Web API and it
draws some pictures for you so there's
no automatic layout but this is the
context diagram for the spring pet
clinic system it's the user using the
system this is the container diagram
it's the user using the web app the web
acquiescing database and that's the
component diagram so again a slightly
nicer approach to visualization here
again because this is a model we can
generate things like diagram keys
automatically array so now we can you
know focus less on notation and again
it's the diagrams the maps link what you
can actually do with structure eyes the
diagrams is you can double click on a
box and there goes to the next level of
detail down if anyone's seen the control
contoso University sample asp.net sample
again same sort of things so there's an
example user system user web app
database and these are the components in
the contoso University sample those are
the structure Iser diagrams somebody
sent me an email a couple of weeks ago
saying that they'd use the open source
structure eyes of a c-sharp
library and done an export to DG ml d g
ml is natively supported by visual
studio and you get some diagrams that
look like this he's working to make
diagrams look nicer but you get complete
you know hierarchical expandable
diagrams inside visual studio which is
quite cool I don't know whether he's
going to make this opens also commercial
but you know definitely keep an eye out
that so if you hook all of this stuff up
with your build process guess what
happens you get diagrams that reflect
the code and diagrams that are kept up
to date and that's exactly the point
here we shouldn't have to worry about
recreating diagrams every time we make
some major changes to software such
visualization in a nutshell there are
two other parts this talk will just come
the very very shortly documentation this
is what the agile manifesto says about
documentation
these five words have been
misinterpreted massively over the past
15 years and lots of teams don't write
any documents anymore I'm sure you don't
do that do you don't coming the problem
is of course the codes doesn't tell you
everything the codes can't tell you why
decisions were made they can't tell you
you know what the approach is to
security on a holistic point of view
where do we deploy this thing how do we
maintain it and support it whether
errors go that's hard to find just by
scraping information from the code a lot
of people are not teams still take this
approach they create some sort of like
software architecture documents there
are millions of templates out there and
they describe some really useful
information very very badly you know
typically these diagrams these are these
documents are hundreds and hundreds of
pages and a half the stuff is totally
out of date that's why these are called
SADS
that's exactly how it makes you feel
when you have to write these things how
do I approach documentation naming I
like the content in the software
architecture documents I don't
particularly like the implementation
approach in many cases so what I do is I
rename this to be a guidebook a software
guidebook and it's the same thing we saw
at the size of this talk so when it
comes to Jersey you get a guidebook it
gives you a nice simple overview some
nice maps to navigate the unfamiliar
environment that's what the diagram is
to do of course the sites the points of
interest the itineraries so you know
given this island what's important what
should I really go and see apply that to
software systems given my million lines
of code which [ __ ] I'd really talk
about how do we support it deploy it
maintain it so some of the practical
information and also history and culture
I given this software system this code
bases for living for 10 or 20 years why
has it evolved in the way it has let's
write some of this stuff down and
essentially in my documentation on
describing what I can't get from the
code that's it that's my simplest
possible tip I can give you about
documentation here this is a constantly
evolving thing this is not big design up
front where we creates 100 basic
get it baseline and signed off and there
are no more changes to it this is
something we write in you know in
complement to the code and the scope of
this guidebook is a single software
system the single product a single thing
again people say what tooling do we use
I don't care well if you want to use
words go for it your new SharePoint good
luck if you want to use confluence a lot
of teams I work with they use confluence
some of the teams now are using things
like markdown and asciidoc that's crazy
you know one file per section of the
guidebook and then they have an
automated build process takes the acid
takes the markdown does some stuff with
it generates HTML uploads it to a
website subscription so again there are
lots of options for creating
documentation here how long should
documentation be right forget about
numbers of pages it's the wrong measure
imagine I join your team I have no idea
what your software does what I want is
something I can read with a cup of
coffee I have a couple of hours to give
me a good starting point for exploring
the code you fly over to Jersey on the
35 minute flight you read the guidebook
on the way you get to Jersey you don't
know exactly where everything is but you
know what you want to go and see next so
again it's that starting point for
exploration and finally exploring now
sometimes it's really useful to explore
your code base to explore your software
architecture model and that's the thing
once you have a model of your code
different levels of abstraction you can
destroy it in really different ways this
is a Java Script d3 visualization of the
static structure for the spring pet
clinic system so this is a visualization
again provided for free structure Iser
but Java Script d3 is very very simple
and so you can create your own
visualization very very simply so we
have the spring pet clinic software
system the containers the components the
classes the code so for different levels
of abstraction here we zoom in a bit
this is this is showing you all of the
code level elements for this particular
component the different styling i've
applied
allows you to see different things about
these classes or interfaces so this
owner repository thing involved that's
the interface type I've identified for
the components during the component scan
the not bowls with regular fonts the two
of them there these are code elements
classes in this case that are only part
of this component and the gray code
level elements are actually shared
between this and other components so
again you can apply some additional
levels of exploration on top of a really
simple model if you have a map of your
components and their dependencies you
can draw things like the Ben C maps so
these are all of the components and the
spring pet clinic web app what I've done
is I've selected the clinic service and
the different color lines are showing me
ingoing and outgoing dependencies if
there was some site click the pen sees
we could highlight those things in red
if you have some notion of size or
complexity again you can do something
like a bubble graph so this is showing
you all of the components from the
spring pet clinic web app ranked upon
size where size is basically numbers of
lines of code that make up that
component you double click to zoom in
you can see all of the code level
elements again how big they are if you
want to do more around exploring code
bases something I would recommend is
going to have a look at a product called
code scene if anyone's familiar with
atom torn Hill and his code as a crime
scene book
he's imited to his company they've built
some tooling to explore a code base in
addition to lots of similar kind of
static analysis it actually does some
human analysis on top so it's a you
point at your source code system and it
starts to show you know how do these
people map onto this code base and it
starts you can ask questions like you
know are we following columns or commas
or breaking ends on and so forth so it's
a really interesting stuff in there
right quick summary
so the 2009 so there was a there's an
article on infocomm from 2009 and it was
a virtual discussion panel on the future
of software architects documentation
there are some big names here Grady
Booch LEM bass or in woods
and I've highlighted some really into
doing things here yeah we want to see
the architecture in the code we want to
embed information we want to get
information free with a click of a
button I don't think we're there yet but
hopefully some of the techniques and
ideas and a tooling I showed you helps
us get bit more towards that vision I
have two things to fight to finish off
with number one the 1990s is calling and
it once is to land back please please
please be please stop using video all
Gliffy or lucid charts or draw day or
any of those general-purpose diagramming
tools for describing software and more
importantly whatever tool you use
whether it's whiteboards or pieces of
paper within your team boundaries focus
on the abstractions first so make sure
you know how you're going to describe
your systems and then let the notation
evolve that's the simplest advice I
could give you there so make sure you do
have that you big's language in your
team boundaries if you're more
information on any of this stuff i've
spoken about you can grab my books off
lean pub you can actually read these for
free online and all of the stuff we've
talked about is in this book here number
two that's me done thank you very much
any questions yes oh I think the
question says question is how much
design and architecture and diagram
should you do it front before you start
writing code for me the short answer is
I'm trying to do just enough right and
that sounds a bit kind of blase but for
me just enough is it's basically doing
enough thinking to understand the
structure of what you're building so in
real concrete terms for me this means
designing down to level of components
and stopping so once you design down to
levels of components which you can do
very very quickly you get a really good
view of how your responsibilities are
carved up across a system so down to
component level design unless you do
micro versus you stop one level up you
need to draw some diagrams like the
diagrams I showed you so that's a really
great way to share that vision and those
are tech side
is with other people on your team and
it's also about risks so you look at
your design say right where are our
major risks you do a kind of risk
identification exercise and then you
might spike out some of those risky
parts so that's my typical approach to
doing upfront design and you know
drawing the diagram is doing the design
even for big systems you can do in a few
days or a week you add a bit of
prototyping proof of concept so you know
for me I'd have an upfront design phase
of a small number of weeks excellent
question
yes
so it's the questions what's stopping
this one game or attraction it actually
is gaining more structure more traction
so you should see my calendar is nuts
the the universities are starting to
realize that UML is not being used in
industry some of the the better
universities I've done some work with
their University lectures are actually
part-time software developers and
part-time lecturers and what I see in
those kind of more practical approaches
to to university courses is that then
they're now teaching things like my C
formal in universities because they
realize when these people get out into
industry the whole UML thing is just
wasted so we're getting there slowly
there are other architectural formats
sysml our cue mates begin the usage of
those is very thin on the ground any
questions over here yes structure Iser
so I mean that's how I do this yeah so
that the purpose of creating any tooling
is to go back to creating real models of
a software system so the probably got
with static diagrams is that you make a
change here you have to make that change
in a bunch of other places if you go
back to tools like rattle rose rational
Software Architect
sparks Enterprise Architect although
those tools are big and complex and they
tend to favor argument in you mailers
notations the concept is still the same
they're trying to give you a way to
create a model of your software system
you dragged the model elements on to
diagram canvases you rename the thing in
the model and the diagrams magically
update so you know tooling aside what I
would urge people to do is is to think
about creating a model of their software
system and ideally trying to get that
model created as automatically from the
code base as possible
anything else over there yeah so
- two crates and diagrams yeah so the
question is if you have an existing code
base how do you go about tracing some
diagrams from it and what I would tend
to do is I would tend to try and look at
the code base and see right how can I
identify components from this code base
oh yeah start the bottom start the
classes start understanding how you
think about the code base you know what
do you consider to be a component are
using a layered architecture ports and
adapters architecture you know how do
you carve out component boundaries
around sets of classes in some code
bases that's really easy to do because
it's been designed and built in a nice
well-structured way if you have a more
of a horrible legacy messy code base
that's a bit tricky to do and sometimes
you just have to say sorry we can't
diagram this system because it's just
really a mess and sometimes that gives
you the empty the incentive you need to
go inside things refactoring so on on
existing code bases are definitely
grinding it can be tricky excellent
thank very much again